Primero de Mayo en Colombia día del
trabajador y los principales sindicatos
del país han salido a las calles
llamados por el presidente Gustavo Petro
que busca el apoyo popular para pasar
sus reformas laboral pensional y de la
salud así nos lo cuenta Persia oyó La
presidente de la confederación general
de trabajadores y por primera vez en 200
años de vida republicana los colombianos
tenemos un gobierno progresista con el
cual el movimiento sindical colombiano
ha debatido y ha presentado propuestas
en materia de reforma laborales estatuto
del trabajo y también en materia
pensional detrás la casa de nariño es la
residencia del presidente Gustavo Petro
y está preparado ya el balcón donde va a
defender las reformas es la segunda vez
que lo hace ya lo hizo el 14 de febrero
por la reforma de salud este día llega
una semana después de una crisis de
gobierno en la que Gustavo Petro cambió
a siete ministros después de romper la
coalición con los partidos de derecha de
la u y el conservador y en lo que ha
sido visto como un giro a la izquierda
sus partidarios le respaldan Hemos
salido al llamado de nuestro presidente
Gustavo Petro porque lo seguimos
respaldando como lo hicimos en las
elecciones y respaldamos los cambios que
él hace en su ministerio porque son para
el bien del país ocho semanas por
delante tiene el gobierno de Gustavo
Petro para pasar la reformas en el
congreso y este lunes también será el
día en el que el presidente viaje a
España para reunirse con el presidente
gobierno español Pedro Sánchez y el rey
de España Felipe